[Music]
jorge
good afternoon it's a question on the
judo case
the commission sent three payment
requests to poland
and a second letter in confirming that
they haven't sent any payment and they
con they continue to breach
the court order um if i'm not wrong uh
15 days after the second letter and some
preparatory work the commission should
start upsetting against the police funds
you fancy allocated to poland so my
question is when did you send the second
letter and how did this preparatory work
on going
thank you i think i can confirm indeed
that the second letter
uh went out uh the work is uh therefore
uh ongoing but i'll bring i'll ask
balash to come to the to the
podium to give you the details
yeah good afternoon i think because of
the complex nature of the topic it is
indeed in order to uh do a bit of a
summary of what has been done on this
very question so just to recall here the
um the fundamental decision is a interim
order from the court of justice going
back to the 21st of may ordering poland
to
close down
the mine in in tour of now because of
the non-compliance of the member state
um on the 20th of september last year
the court ordered a ordered poland
rather to pay a daily penalty of half a
million euro for failure of compliance
now it is for the commission to collect
this fine what we did in the beginning
was to reach out to the polish
authorities to see how they intend to
carry out the interim order of of the
court
now given that we
could not identify any sign of of the
polish authorities seeking to do so um
we indeed proceeded as per the procedure
as per the standard procedure with the
sending of so-called calls for payment
now i have a couple of uh dates at my uh
disposal um
before we jump in i should i should add
that every time we send a call for
payment we are looking at a period of
one month
so the payment is due as of the 20th of
september which is the day when the
court
imposed imposed
define so the first call for payment
concerns a period going from the 20th of
uh september until until the 19th of
october now this uh first call was sent
out on the
10th of
november with a deadline of 45 days as
you have just said the payment was not
received during this period which is why
the commission proceeded with a
so-called reminder letter which has a
deadline of 15
15 days now should the
authorities
of poland not carry out the payment then
of course the commission has
robust procedures to go a step further
and recover recover the fine and that
would be done
via of setting the sum mentioned in the
first call for payment against the
payment that
the member state is due to receive
from
from the eu budget so that would be my
opening statement but i'm sure you will
have full of questions
jorge
yes so
10 november 10 december 25th december so
we are you're about i mean this 15 day
deadline it's already over right now if
i don't know
no this is not the case the 15 day
deadline is not over yet i don't know if
i could keep the precise dates um so the
second letter was sent out on the 3rd of
january so the 15 day deadline actually
would count from the moment where the
authorities
the polish authorities acknowledged the
receipt of the of the second letter so
we are still in the 15 day period okay
and
what will happen after the 15 day period
that's one question and then since every
payment request it's uh refers to one
month period that means that you will
offset only that one month period the
part of the fine meaning 15 million
euros more or less
um so so what is important here is that
the 45-day
initial sort of deadline will expire at
different moments for the different
intervals so for the second one-month
period it will come to an end a little
bit later because we sent the call for
payment later now um obviously i'm not
going to speculate what will happen
because that would be a speculative
question this moment but i can tell you
about the procedure uh what happens and
how the commission in general recovers
uh such fines so i think it's it's just
important to say that the
um
the decision here on which we operate is
dating back to 2018.
so once we get to the stage whereby the
second deadline expired our budget
department takes over
and we'll look at different upcoming
payments
that would go
from the eu budget towards the member
state
question and will identify an
appropriate payment against which
the off setting could be could be could
be made
once the
appropriate payment is identified we
inform
the member state
concerned and once that's the case um we
carry out the offsetting procedure in 10
after 10 working days
last question
sorry about that yeah very final
question um so then 10 additional days
so that would mean the 28th of january
moles or end of january when you will
complete the procedure
and then if you could confirm that this
is the first time the commission is
using this procedure as well
what i can confirm is that um in the
past um we have never had a case whereby
a fine imposed by the court of justice
on a member state would not be would not
be paid that i can i can confirm now in
terms of the dates i mean i'm not going
to
speculate on exact dates at the moment
you have the moment you have the date
when the second letter was sent you can
calculate when it when the deadline will
expire and then you also know what would
happen afterwards so i think it would be
it would be responsible now to be more
specific on the dates
i think the key point to remember here
is that
whatever the exact timing you know one
day more one day less
there is an inevitability
to the fact that uh when
a when the court of justice has
issued a fine to a member state
that money
will one way or another
be paid to
to the eu budget
and then of course from a treasury
management point of view from a
procedural point of view you have to go
through different steps with with
timelines and stuff like that but
but fundamentally at the end of the day
it means that either the member state
complies with the judgment
or until the point where it complies
with the judgment these payments are due
and
recovered by uh by the european
commission on behalf of the on behalf of
the union and we are now in the throes
of this
of this procedure
and will continue to carry through
right
any other questions on this specific
issue
i see two hands raised in
the
interaxio platform
but
i would like to make sure that they are
about
this specific
issue if not please
unders
your hands
so that is not the case thank you very
much um
so i go back to hey aquida
i'm not sure pronouncing that well but
it's my
best effort
happy to be trained
for you
uh it's concerning the letter of 30 meps
that sent yesterday to president ursula
von der lion about commissioner
vargheli's role in the crisis of bosnia
and herzegovina first can you confirm
that you indeed receive this letter and
do you intend to undertake
an inquiry about his actions in the
crisis in bosnia and herzegovina and if
they are compatible with his role as
commissioner for enlargement as
asked by those 30 meps in the letter
thank you
thank you
i'm certainly aware of the letter since
i believe it has been tweeted i believe
we have received it okay and of course
as always we will answer
the letter from the mbp so we will
reserve our answer
to
the questions raised by the meps to our
answer
um
you have a follow-up
indeed i have a follow-up uh
commissioner hello but together with
other
european actors were actively involved
in bosnia and segovina crisis this is a
burning issue in the region however you
must be informed about what everything
does everybody does especially one of
your commissioners so are these actions
his engagements
in line and within the mandate of him as
a commissioner for enlargement
thank you um well i believe that the
commissioner himself
came out after
the visit which he made to bosehzna
in november with extremely clear
statements
on
the efforts that
the authorities the public authorities
of barcelona and how the governor have
to undertake
to pursue their european path and these
statements are obviously as you would
expect entirely
representative of the eu's and the
commission's position in this
in this matter
this is what i have to say
as i have said for the rest we will of
course answer the letter from the
members of parliament in due time
right um any other questions related to
uh the situation in bosnian health
for us
sebastian you have a question on this
morning thank you uh well my question is
on a different uh matter is regarding
energy um
then i'm sorry you will have to wait uh
sebastian we will come back to you on
energy
at a later point in time augustine you
have another question
uh yes thank you it's still about bosnia
herzegovina
you are aware and you are saying in many
statements that there is a political
crisis in bosnia herzegovina
the main reason and everything started
after uh the former high representative
in bosnia herzegovina imposed the law
for
uh considering a denial of genocide in
srebrenica's criminal offense
this might be according to the standard
eu standards because you encourage
everybody to
uh how to say not not to deny genocide
war crimes not to glorify
war criminals but allegedly while in
sarajevo commissioner fairhead he said
that
this decision made
the problem worse than it is
and not the actions of milorad dodig and
uh others in boston arena so
what is the position of the commission
do you consider
uh that the decision to make denial of
genocide
created a problem or
your position is still that there is no
place in europe to deny genocide because
we we get confusing uh
positions from the eu officials thank
you
thank you very much this would be a
question for anar for peter
peter
well b is correct your second part is
correct there is no place in europe and
in european union for denial of genocide
there is no place in the european union
and it's not in line with european
values and principles to glorify war
crimes to incite hatred and to come up
with a provocative statement
the position of the european union when
it comes to bosnia herzegovina is very
clear it has been repeated and recalled
many times most recently in our
statement on monday
and the position of the eu is formed by
27 member states who are very clear when
it comes to expectations from bosnia in
the accession process and when it comes
to our expectations
of behavior of the leaders political
leaders in bosnia-herzegovina it has
been recalled on many occasions as i
said most recently on monday
thank
you right any other questions on
this issue yogi
yes
thank you thank you eric
it's
it's very close actually
a famous russian opposition politician
vladimir karamorza
said that
serbia's interior minister alexander
wulin
has given to the kremlin
transcripts of wired up conversation
between
russian opposition members
and uh as a result uh andrey pivarov
the former director of
the ngo open russia was
arrested
my question is
also having in mind what petter said
yesterday
how much can the commission take in
terms of you know
infringement of what is considered
normal
[Music]
following of
european policy with respect to russia
from a
country on its way to accession as
serbia
thank you
thank you um
right well i think we've moved on now
from bosnia-herzegovina but i don't see
any other questions on this anyway so
peter go ahead
thank you georgie i'm not really sure
which aspect of uh your extensive
question you want me to tackle but uh on
the allegations and counter allegations
regarding the alleged wiretapping we we
are aware about what is going on what
has been said by one side and the other
there are allegations there are counter
allegations so if there are any doubts
about wrongdoings in terms of
wiretapping anyone
that needs to be of course properly
investigated and clarified um on the
second thing in how far or what does it
take
for the commissioner for the member
states well i mean countries in the
accession process are apprised and
their progress is reviewed regularly in
terms of the annual reports where all
the developments are being taken into
account when it comes specifically to
the
issues of rule of law judiciary reforms
et cetera et cetera are pretty well
defined areas which i'm sure you are
very familiar with when it comes to
foreign policy of the of the applicants
and candidate countries it's very clear
that the eu expects the gradual
alignment with eu is foreign policy and
eu foreign positions and this is also
something that is being watched um
evaluated by the member states and by
the institutions and based on these the
decisions about next steps in the
accession process are being made so all
these what is going on all the doubts
all the progress all the rigorous is
taken into account and evaluated
regularly
okay thank you very much um taking into
account the fact that uh there are press
conferences on foreign affairs related
issues taking place
um
in brest today and tomorrow i will now
close the
foreign affairs
chapter
and move on to
other issues also in view of the fact
that we have executive vice president
vestar coming shortly in the press room
thank you peter sebastian we go to your
question on energy
go ahead
which is uh spreading to asia's
developing economies for example sorry
sebastian so you started speaking before
your mic was turned on so we missed the
beginning of your question
just make sure you connect first
and only start speaking afterwards if
you want us to understand your question
sorry can you hear me now
no it's great go ahead sorry my first
time in the in the platform my question
is uh regarding energy taking into
account um what we're seeing in india
and indonesia uh which for example india
recently bought spot lng cargos after
being largely absent from the market and
indonesia which is a
a major exporter asked its gas producers
to prioritize local customers this
happens at the same time when in europe
uh the prices of the gas are rising so i
would like to know if this situation is
impacting europe somehow and uh how are
you um analyzing this situation how are
you going to tackle it
thank you
thank you
so first question is whether those
decisions already have a concrete impact
on uh the prices paid by europe i guess
uh in terms of a gas that it is
purchasing
and are we monitoring the situation yeah
uh a new angle to the energy prices uh
discussion we've been having for a
little while now um as as you perhaps
know i mean the the commission's
analysis and that's shared
by by all experts is that the the
current energy price
increases are driven
by global demand by a supply squeeze
which is all against the background of
the the economic recovery from kovid
the the growth in the asian
economy uh recovery of the asian economy
and increasing demand
demand therefore for gas is one of the
factors that of course
has that knock-on effect on prices in
europe and other places so it's
something that of course we continue
uh to keep an eye on um we continue to
close very closely monitor the situation
on the markets and and what changes
around the world are making but i
wouldn't have any specific comment to
make
on developments in those countries at
the moment
thank you tim any other questions on
energy for us today
no thank you any other issues for us
that is not the case so
thank you
and we will
reconvene at one
for the press conference by executive
vice president of stage thank you very
much